américa latina fue la región donde hubo
un mayor aumento del hambre en 2020 son
10 millones de personas en situación de
inseguridad alimentaria el triple que
antes de la llegada del cob y 19 así lo
advirtió en conversación con france24
carlos caramella representante del
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu
están confirmando
y el acceso en ocasión es la primera
necesidad preocupa a centroamérica
especialmente las comunidades rurales
del llamado corredor seco el informe
reveló que sólo una de cada diez
familias encuestadas cuentan con una
seguridad alimentaria adecuada cuando la
pandemia entonces todo se cerró ya no
nos dejaban ni salir entonces ya no
podíamos trabajar
para poder traer un alimento a la casa
en sudamérica el foco está puesto en
perú donde las ollas comunes aumentaron
de 337 a más de 1300 con la llegada del
cob y 19 son cocinas comunitarias
vecinales impulsadas por mujeres que
sirven de emergencia alimentaria también
preocupa colombia una encuesta 34 mil
familias reveló que el 80 por ciento de
ellas en su mayoría migrantes
venezolanas no cubren sus necesidades
básicas la onu pide un mayor esfuerzo
gubernamental el ampliamente del alcance
de los sistemas canciones de protección
social es una medida fundamental es una
medida que naturalmente y sigue también
una serie de otras otras medidas
relacionadas con la capacidad de
registrar por ejemplo los migrantes
irregulares según las naciones unidas la
pandemia deja 45 millones de nuevos
pobres en américa latina' efectos que
van de la mano del impacto del cob y 19
la región concentra una tercera parte de
contagios pese a tener menos del 10 por
ciento de la población mundial